[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم حين صعد انور ابراهيم الى سده
رئاسه الوزراء في ماليزيا نهايه نوفمبر
الماضي قالت مجله الفرن بوليسي ان الرجل
فاز باسوء وظيفه في بلاده لم يكن هذا
التعبير الا اشاره الى المهمه الشاقه التي
تنتظر ابراهيم في قياده ماليزيا البلد
المضطرب سياسيا المتراجع اقتصاديا
والمستشري فيه الفساد فخلال الاعوام
العشره الاخيره تعاقب على منصب رئاسه
الوزراء في ماليزيا سياسيون كثر اشتركوا
جميعا في العجز امام الاحوال المتفاقمه في
البلاد والاخفاق في ايجاد حلول لها ومن
عجب ان كان من بينهم ايه السياسه في
ماليزيا محمد الرمز الذي شكل مصدر الهام
عالمي طيله عقود وفي الاقتصاد ترزح البلاد
تحت وطاه عجز متزايد ودين متفاقم وارتفاع
في تكاليف المعيشه وهو ما يهدد صوره
ماليزيا كنموذج طالما جذب بريقه انظار دول
العالم الثالث المتطلعه الى النهوض اما
التحدي الاخطر فيتمثل في تعزيز قيم
الشفافيه والنزاهه ونظافه اليد بين الطبقه
السياسيه وكبار المسؤولين وما قضيه
الصندوق الماليزي التي اخذت بعدا دوليا
الا عرضا للمرض الذي طال قمه هرم السلطه
في البلاد مجتمعيا ينتظر ان تعمل حكومه
ابراهيم على ارساء المساواه بين جميع
المكونات الاثنيه في البلاد بعد انتقادات
الراجت في السنوات الاخيره لتمييز مارسته
الحكومات السابقه لصالح عرقيه الملايو
والتي تشكل الاغلبيه على حساب عرقيتين
الهنود والصينيين الماليزيين كذلك فان
الحكومه الجديده ستكون مطالبه بتوثيق
الروابط بالدوائر الاسلاميه والعربيه فضلا
عن التحلي بحكمه كبيره في اداره علاقات
ماليزيا الدوله الاستراتيجيه في قلب منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ بكل من الولايات
المتحده والصين في ظل سجلات تتجدد بين
البلدين من حين لاخر مشاهدينا الكرام رئيس
الوزراء الماليزي انور ابراهيم ضيف
المقابله في هذه الحلقه والحلقه التي
تليها فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
تقلد منصب رئيس الوزراء في ماليزيا منذ
نوفمبر عام 2022 ولد عام
1947 ويعد من رواد التيار الاسلامي
الاصلاحي في ماليزيا اسس وتراسل الاتحاد
الماليزي الشباب المسلمين بين عامي 71 و
1982 اعجب مهاتير محمد بنشاطه فدعاه
للالتحاق بحزب امنو عام 82 ارتقى سريعا
داخل الحزب واصبح احد ابرز شخصياته شغل
وزارات عده بين عامي 83
و98 اهمها الماليه والزراعه والتربيه عرض
رؤيته لنهضه ماليزيا في كتاب النهضه
الاسيويه عام
1996 في العام التالي توترت علاقته بمهات
محمد نتيجه الازمه الاقتصاديه الاسيويه
طرح حلا لتراجع الاقتصاد الماليزي استنادا
الى اسس ليبراليه جذب قلوبه دعم مجتمع
الاعمال الغربي والدوائر السياسيه
الامريكيه واتهم بالفساد وصدر ضده حكم
بالسجن بعد ادانته عام
1998 جرت تبرئه واطلق سراحه في عام 2004
بعد استقاله مهاتير محمد عاد الى السياسه
من باب التحالف مع المعارضه وانتخب نائبا
بالبرلمان الماليزي عام 2008 حيث طالب
باجراء اصلاحات تزعم المعارضه في البرلمان
خلال الفتره بين عامين 2008 و2015
ودافع عن حريه الصحافه والاقتصاد الحر
وطالب بمكافحه الفساد حكم عليه بالسجن
مجددا عام 2015 بعد نقض الحكم السابق
بتبرئته تصالح مع مهاتر محمد وعاد للتحالف
معه وفازا بالاغلبيه عام 2018 انشق مع بعض
الشخصيات عمهاتير في عام 2020 وكلف بتشكيل
الحكومه بعد تصدر تحالف الامل الذي يتزعمه
الانتخابات في عام 2022
مشاهدينا الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته اهلا بكم الى حلقه جديده من
المقابله حلقه استثنائيه من هنا من
ماليزيا من كوالالمبورة ستضيف رئيس
الوزراء الماليزي السيد انور ابراهيم
مرحبا بك سيد انور ابراهيم في المقابله
شكرا متابع برنامج المقابله واتطلع الى
مشاهدته حينما نتحدث عن رئيس الوزراء قادم
من مشوار طويل من العذابات ومن السجن
نتذكر مانديلا وهنا ايضا نتذكر انور
ابراهيم السياسي الماليزي الاستثنائي الذي
خاض مشوارا سياسيا طويلا كان في كثير من
المعاناه ابدا قبل ان تتحدث عن السياسه
سيد انور ابراهيم ما شعورك اليوم وانت على
سده رئاسه الوزراء بعد عذابات السجن
الطويله في مشوارك الاخير
ليس طويلا مثل مشوار منديلا السياسي عندما
التقيت به قبل سنوات بعد فتره وجيزه من
اطلاق سواحل للمره الاولى للمره الثانيه
وقلت له انني على مسافه قصيره من الحريه
كان قد قضى سبعه وعشرين عاما وكنت قد غضيت
ما يقارب احد عشر عاما اذا كنت عازما على
محاوله القيام بما هو افضل لبلدك فعليك ان
تتطلع الى حياه افضل ويجب ان تكون قادرا
على التسامح على الرغم من انك لست بحاجه
بالضروره الى النسيان لذلك انت تسامح
وتمضي قدما هل كان المشوار مستحقا لكل هذه
المعاناه برايك
[موسيقى]
حسنا يجب ان تسال زوجتي واولادي عما قاسوا
ايضا كما العديد من اصدقائه لكن اذا كنا
قادرين على الوفاء بما وعدنا به اذا
استطعنا انقاذ هذا البلد من الانهيار
الاقتصادي فيما يتعلق بالحوكمه والفساد
فانا اعتقد ان شاء الله انه للافضل
جرت محاولات كثيره سيد انور ابراهيم
لتلطيخ سمعه انور ابراهيم عبر اتهامات
يعني كان واضحا انها مسيسه واليوم تعود
تعود بقياده تحالف وطني لرئاسه وزراء
ماليزيا تشعر ان هذا رد على كل ما تعرضت
له
حسنا علينا الاستمرار يمكنني التحدث عن
الصعوبات التي اواجهها لكن معاناتي تبدو
بسيطه مقارنه بالعديد من الصعوبات الاخرى
انا طالب تاريخ انا طالب في التاريخ
الاسلامي وقد كافح الناس وضح الناس انا
دائما اقرا حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم اي الناس اشد بلاء ونوقن اننا جميعا
نواجه مشاكل وسالنا النبي محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ولكن الجواب لسنا نحن انما
الاجابه الانبياء ثم الامثل فالامثل لذلك
اعتقد انه اذا اخذنا هذا المثال فقد كنت
قدمت القليل من التضحيه لا تتحدث عن ذلك
كثيرا ولكن فقط امضي قدما لانها مهمه
الرساله الاكبر في الحياه التي يتعين عليك
القيام بها
في الحمله الانتخابيه سيدنا ابراهيم
استخدمت شعارا مقاربا لما استخدمه باراك
اوباما يسوي كان نعم نحن نستطيع تستطيعون
ماذا تحديدا ما الذي تريدون تحقيقه لهذه
البلاد
[موسيقى]
ويصيب من ليس هذا
حسنا كما ترى حققت ماليزيا مستوى معينا من
النجاح في الماضي في الجانب الاقتصادي
ولكنه انهار ولم يعد ينظر اليه على انه
مثال اسلامي او نموذج يحتذى لذا فان
التحدي يكمل في التاكد من ان لدينا حوكمه
مناسبه في وقف هدر الاموال العامه وتحقيق
الترشيد والتركيز على البرامج الاقتصاديه
التي تعود بالنفع على الوطن والشعب
التفاوت بين الاغنياء والفقراء لا يزال
واسعا لا يزال لدينا في بلد يتمتع بوفره
في النفط والغاز والزراعه والصناعه لكن لا
يزال بعض شرائح الفقر الشديد والفقر
المتقع خصوصا بين غالبيه المسلمين
والملايو في هذا البلد
لقد كنا نتحدث عن تفوق الملايو ودوله
الملايو ولكن الافقر هم الملايو اذا هناك
تناقض هنا لذلك فان مهمتي هي مكافحه
الفساد وبناء الاقتصاد والمساعده والعمل
على ضمان توزيع عادل لجميع الموارد حتى
تتمكن ماليزيا من النهوض مره اخرى كدوله
موحده
قلت في مقابله سابقه انك ورثت بلد
دوله ملوثه بالفضائح والكسب غير المشروع
على النص دوله ملوثه بالفضائح والكسب غير
المشروع ما حجم الفساد الذي توجهه اليوم
انور ابراهيم رئيس الوزراء
دوال حسنا لقد قلت ان هذا الفساد منهجي
الغده وان العالم سمع عن فضيحه الصندوق
السيادي الماليزي التي اثرت سلبا على قوه
اقتصادنا لم يكن هذا ليحدث لو كان النظام
مطبقا اثر القضاء والمؤسسات التنفيذيه
والبنك المركزي بطريقه ما بعض الاخفاقات
في السماح بحدوث ذلك
وبالطبيعه الحال المؤسسه المصرفيه الدوليه
مثل جولد مان ساكس لكن هذا ليس سوى جزء
بسيط لقد بحثت الان واصبحت ايضا وزير
الماليه وفي المخصصات الماليه في كل مشروع
كبير من
هناك عمولات ضخمه واموال ضخمه يتم ارسالها
الى الاحزاب والافراد الان لا يمكن للبلد
ان يتحرك على هذا النحو لذا فان مهمتي هي
محاوله التطهير باستمرار الامر ليس سهلا
لانك تتعامل مع اشخاص اقوياء واثرياء جدا
لكن اي لدينا هل تريد ان يستمر هذا توقف
عن اليوم غير المسلمين او لون الصينيين او
لون الملايو لا نحن نلوم الفساد ولذلك
علينا تطهير العمليه انه امر صعب لكنني
اعتقد ان العديد من الماليزيين وموظفي
الخدمه المدنيه وقاده الشركات ورجال
الاعمال
والقاده السياسيين والاشخاص يرغبون في
رؤيه ماليزيا جديده باقتصاد نابض بالحياه
وعادل ونزيه واكثر ديمقراطيه طلبت
الناخبين ان تحصل على اغلبيه مريحه حتى
تستطيع مواجهه الفساد انت لم تستطع الحصول
على هذه الاغلبيه المريحه فبالتالي يبدو
ان مواجهتكم مع الفساد ستكون صعبه نتيجه
هذا التحالف الذي طرتم له
[موسيقى]
لا ليس صحيحا تماما لاننا كنا اكبر تحالف
بعد الانتخابات وكانت المعارضه قويه جدا
وتشكل ثلث البرلمان لكننا بعد ذلك نشكل
اتلافا بعجينه واضحه تتضمن النقطه الاولى
الحكم الرشيد ما يعني اننا نكافح الفساد
النقطه الثانيه على الرغم من انها اغلبيه
مسلمه من الملايو وتحافظ على الاسلام كدين
رسمي للدوله فقد قبلنا حقيقه ان هذا البلد
متعدد الاعراق والاديان يمنح حقوقا قضائيه
لغير المسلمين ومن ثم التركيز على
الاقتصاد واعاده احياء وانعاش الاقتصاد
ليصبح قوه هائله في المنطقه
والان تم اختبارها في البرلمان في اولى
جلساته لانه عندما عينني الملك اخبرته
انني ساستمر اذا من تامين اغلبيه مريحه في
البرلمان لذا فانا اؤيد الحركه وكان لدينا
دعم ثلثي البرلمان في الواقع تم تقديم
الاقتراح ولم تكن هناك معارضه لمنح الثقه
للحكومه الان مرت ثلاثه اشهر والتحالف
اقوى بكثير بين الاحزاب الرئيسيه في شبه
الجزيره في مالايا ايضا في ولايتي صباح
وسرواك لذلك لا احد يشكك الان في حقيقه
انها حكومه مستقره وقويه وتركز الان على
مكافحه الفساد والتجاوزات وستوجه جهودها
تجاه الاقتصاد انت اضطررت لائتلاف حكومي
يعني سته من اعضاء الوزاره السيد انور هم
من حزب امنوا فيهم من هو متهم
بالفساد وبالتالي تبدو المساله اكثر
تعقيدا في مواجهه الفساد
لانني
ان اداره منزل مكون من زوجه واطفال ليس
بالامر سهل فكيف باداره حكومه بالطبع لا
بد ان الامر اكثر تعقيدا ولا سيما في ظل
وجود تحالف متعدد العراق ومتعدد الاديان
لكن يجب ان اشد بالملك الذي نسميه
بالملاويه ياندي بارتوان اجونغ ويعني لقب
الحاكم الاعلى في ماليزيا هنا بعد استشاره
سلاطين الاقاليم كان لديه الحكمه
الاستشراف المستقبل بالطبع لتعيين الحزب
الذي يتمتع بالاغلبيه
لكنه كان يفكر للمستقبل انك بحاجه الى
حكومه موحده ومستقره وقبل تلك النصيحه من
الملك وبدا المفاوضات الان يتفاوضون على
اساس المبادئ والسياسات هل يمكن ان نتفق
على انه بلد الفساد نعم هل يمكننا ان نتفق
على ان تبقى ماليزيا موحده من كل الاجناس
والاديان نعم ان نتفق على ان الاسلام دين
الدوله الاتحاد والملايو بما في ذلك
السلاطين ماذا يوجد في الدستور الجواب نعم
ثم نمضي الان العديد من القاده ليسوا
كثيرين القليل منهم تم اتهامهم او تلويثهم
ارى انه اذا كانوا متهمين فانهم يخضعون
للاجراءات وليس لي ان اقرر انه متهمون
وغير مدانين اذا ادينوا لا يمكنهم الخدمه
لكنه متهمون وقلت ان القضاء مستقل هيئه
القضاء والنيابه العامه مهنيه وعليهم ان
يخضعوا للايراد لكن لا يمكن للمعارضه ان
تستغل القضيه لان قاده المعارضه وكثير
منهم متهمون بالفساد بشكل هائل لكن لانهم
كانوا في السلطان وهم يتمتعون بحصانه الان
انا اقول بغض النظر عن من انت اذا كنت
متورطا في التهرب بشكل كبير وتبديد
الاموال فيجب ان يتم التحقيق معك اما من
حزب او من المعارضه بغض النظر لذا بالنسبه
لهؤلاء الذين يقترحون انه نظرا لان
الاشخاص الملوثين يخدمون الحكومه يجب
القول انه يتعين عليهم دون استثناء المضي
في الاجراءات والسماح للمحكمه المستقله
باتخاذ القرار هل تثق بالقضاء بشكل كافي
في في محاكماته لسياسين
علي
حسنا لقد مررت بتجربه مع القضاء في الماضي
يا علي انت على حق لكن في السنوات القليله
الماضيه كانت هناك نقله نوعيه وسلطه
القضائيه الان تثبت نفسها وانا كرئيس
الوزراء وجهت رساله قاطعه الى القضاء ان
التعيينات والقرارات يجب ان تكون محايده
تماما بناء على الحقائق والقانون وبالتالي
اعتقد ان القضاء لا يشبه اي قطاع اخر يعمل
في نظام تسيطر فيه السلطه التنفيذيه ومن
ثم تحصل لديهم مشكله
ولكن هنا اعني انت كسلطه تنفيذيه وهنا انت
مستقل تلتزم بالقانون ومفاعيل القانون
وتحكم قضائيا وانت مسؤول ليس فقط امام
الناس ولكن في النهايه امام الله سبحانه
وتعالى
هل تمت اجراءات سيد انور ابراهيم اتخذت
بحيث تضمن نزاهه واستقلاليه القضاء لا
يمكن للديمقراطيه ان تكتمل ولا للحظه
اقتصاديه ان تكتمل بدون قضاء نزيه ومستقل
فما هي الاجراءات التي يمكن ان تساعد
القضاء الماليزي ان يكون قضاء مستقلا
ونزيها ونحن نعرف تجربه السيد انور
ابراهيم كيف سيس القضاء في مواجهته لاسباب
سياسيه جودي يشتري
القضاء في برنامجنا واضح انت تتحدث عن
الحكم الرشيد يجب ان يتمتع القضاء
بالاستقلال يمكن ان يكون لديك حكم الرشيد
مع سلطه قضائيه وسطيه وقد راينا ذلك لدى
المستثمرين شكوك عندما يواجهون مشكله فهم
غير واثقين مما اذا كان ينبغي عليهم
التقاضي هنا او اللجوء الى القضاء في
سنغافوره او هونج كونج وهذا امر مخزن
بالنسبه لنا لذلك من المهم اعاده ثقه
المستثمرين بالاقتصاد
ما هو اكثر اهميه بالنسبه لي كمسلم
وكمواطن صالح وكديمقراطي انها مهزله تتحدث
عن مجتمع حديث يتعرض فيه القضاء للخطر لقد
تعلمنا من تاريخنا ان سيدنا علي بن ابي
طالب كان يخضع للقضاء وهو خليفه ويتم
اتخاذ القرارات بحياديه بناء على الحقائق
والقانون
نمبر وان بالطبع نحن لاعبون صغار لكن يجب
ان نحاول ما ينبغي ان نفعله لضمان ذلك
النقطه الاولى التعيينات القضائيه التي
يقررها القضاء الا اذا كانت هناك وكالات
تعلق على سجلاتهم السابقه او اي شيء لدينا
لم نقم باتباع ذلك في الاشهر الثلاثه
عندما كنت في السلطه النقطه الثانيه
اكاديميه تدريب القضاه لقد قدموا الاقتراح
وانا اراجعه لدعم تدريب القضاه لكن الاهم
من ذلك يا علي بالنسبه لي هو القرار الذي
اتخذته الحكومه والذي اعلنت عنه وهو ان
القضاه والنظام القضائي يجب ان يكون
مستقلا تماما
[موسيقى]
سيد ابراهيم كنت وزير الماليه بان النهضه
الماليزيه الان لماذا اخترت ان تكون وزيرا
للماليه مره اخرى بالاضافه الى كونك رئيس
الوزراء
وزير مالي
حسنا ادركوا ان كونك وزير للماليه مشكله
كافيه بحد ذاتها انها وظيفه بدوام كامل
تقريبا لقد شغلته منصب وزير الماليه لمده
ثمان سنوات في الماضي خلال الاوقات جيده
بالطبع كان النمو تسعه الى عشره في المئه
وكان لدينا ميزانيه متوازنه مبدئيه وفائض
في الميزانيه نحن الان نواجه عجزا ضخما
وديولا ضخمه لم نشهدها من قبل لماذا اتولى
هذا المنصب مع ان منصب رئيس الوزراء فيه
من الاعباء ما يكفيني وبسبب
مشكله الحوكمه والموافقه على المشاريع دون
تعقيد لتغيير ذلك يجب ان اكسب ثقه قطاع
الخدمه المدنيه وبعض المهنيين وربما ان
اقدم التوجيهات واضحه واتبعوا مسارا محددا
حتى يقوم وزير الماليه القادم المكلف امل
ان يكون قريبا بمتابعه هذا الامر ارا ذلك
لان وزاره الماليه في ظل هذه الاداره ربما
تكون حريه للغايه لاننا نواجه تحديات
اقتصاديه كبيره
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب انا اتولى مسؤولياتها لبعض
الوقت على الرغم من انها ثقيله الى حد ما
حتى ان زوجتي تشكو على اي حال نعم
اريد ان اعرف اجنده انور ابراهيم الماليه
لدينا الدين العام تريليون ونصف التريليون
ماليزي ما يعادل 350 مليار 150 بالمئه من
الناتج القومي وهذا تكاد تكون يعني ارقام
مخيفه فما هي خطه الدكتور انور ابراهيم
لمواجهه هذه الازمه الماليه التي تواجه
ماليزيا
فقط بضع مئات من الملايين في الوقت الحاضر
تتحدث احيانا عن المليارات
كانت هناك حاله وفاه وزير سابق وكانت هناك
مشاكل داخل الاسره وهكذا ادركوا ان ثروته
كانت
مليارينغت وجميعها من الرقم المتسلسل على
الارقام النقديه
الان نتعامل مع وثائق بنما الاشخاص الذين
جلبوا لي مليارات الدولارات رجال الاعمال
في نيويورك علي لا يشكل الامر قضيه كبيره
بالنسبه لي لكن اذا كنت وزيرا للماليه
ورئيس الوزراء وتحتفظ بمليار واحد
بالمناسبه هناك كثير من السياسيين
الماليزيين اغنياء جدا
نعم هذه وجهه نظري لكن وثائق بنما هي مثال
على ذلك لا هذا شخص ثري فاسد فاسد لان
الوسائل فاسده وكيفيه التحصيل ايضا لذا
عليهم ان يشرحوها كما قلت يا علي اذا كنت
انت من رجال الاعمال النزيفين فالامر عادل
كما تعلم لكنك وزير الماليه فكيف يتساهل
النظام مع هذا العقود اين مؤسسات تنفيذ
القانون اين البنك المركزي في الايرادات
الداخليه او في هيئه مكافحه الفساد لذلك
قلت لهم انهضوا وقوموا بعملكم وسادعمكم
لانه في الماضي قد فشلوا في الاجراءات
والان اذا تمكنا من النجاح في التعامل
معها فيمكن توفير المليارات النقطه الاولى
يمكن استرداد الاموال ونامل ان نتمكن من
استعاده بضعه مليارات اخرى القضيه الاخرى
بالطبع هي كيف تكسب ثقه مجتمع الاستثمار
الدولي حتى الشركات المحليه والعديد منها
يحجم عن الاستثمار عندك لذلك اذا قدمنا
سياسه واضحه يجب ان تكون شفافه وسلسه
وتسهل ممارسه الاعمال التجاريه وان تكون
نزيهه ولا تتلقى عمولات ونحن نستهدف ما
يمكننا من القضاء على الفقر الامن
الاقتصادي والامن الغذائي والرقمنه ووجود
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه مطلوب ايضا
نجعلها سياسه واضحه جدا
والان على الرغم من انه من السابق لاوانه
ان اقول انه بحلول الاشهر القليله الاولى
رايت من الشرق الاوسط ومن امريكا ومن
الصين ومن الهند ومن اوروبا اقبالا كبيرا
لانهم يرون ان هناك املا وحكم الرشيدا يتم
تطبيقه وسياسه واضحه ساعلن عنها في
الميزانيه القادمه الحرب ضد الفساد يعني
شعار يطلق في كثير من دول العالم يستخدمه
كثير من السياسيين هل نتوقع استعاده اموال
منهوبه مليارات من فاسدين سياسيين في
ماليزيا بحيث تعطى يعني انشاء مؤشرات
مطمئنه سواء المجتمع الاقتصادي المحلي او
المجتمع الدولي الذي يراقب ماليزي هل
نتوقع مليارات تعود من سياسيين يا علي ابن
خالي
لقد كنت ادعو الى هذا الاصلاح في السنوات
الخمس والعشرين الماضيه داخل وخارج السين
ماذا اريد اريد فقط ان ابذل قصار جهدي لا
اريد ان يعرف انور كسياسي يتحدث عن
الشعارات ولا ينفذ كل السياسيين يريدون
تخليص البلاد من الفساد حتى عندما ياخذون
المال لذا فانت محق عليه في تذكيري برؤيه
ذلك مترجما على ارض الواقع
اذا كانت المؤسسات القديمه تعمل بشكل
احترافي فيمكن اعاده بعض الاموال لكن من
الواضح انني لن اتسامح مع اي تجاوزات اي
زعيم في هذا البلد مهما كان مهما كانت
تحالفهم اذا اكتشفت اي شبهه عليه
فستتم اقالته
اكثر ما يقف مهددا لتجربه الماليزيه اليوم
هو الفساد الذي اساء للسيره البلاد وحولها
من النقيض الى النقيض من انموذج للنهوض
رغم العثرات الكثيره والكبيره الى امثوله
للفساد حيث ياتي على ما تحقق من انجازات
السنين اما اشكال الفساد في البلد الاسيوي
فمتعدده منها مشروعات كبرى بمليارات
الدولارات اطلقتها حكومه سابقه كانت عبئا
على اقتصاد البلاد وثقل على كاهل العباد
في مؤشر واضح على غياب الاولويات فضلا عن
ذلك تنوء البلاد بالمحسوبيه التي لم يسلم
منها حزب او منصب فتاثرت بها احزاب السلطه
والمعارضه على حد سواء وطالت كثيرا من
المناصب العامه والى جانب ما تقدم تاتي
قضيه الصندوق الماليزي لتشكل قمه جبل
الجليد ولتكون المنعطف الذي قد تستفيق
بسببه البلاد او تكمل المسير في الدرب الى
الهاويه
انشئ صندوق التنميه الماليزي في عام 2009
ليكون تحت اداره رئيس الوزراء انذاك نجيب
عبد الرزاق وجمع وقتها اموالا قدرت باثني
عشر مليار دولار كان يفترض ضخها في مشروع
لانشاء عاصمه ماليه جديده الى جانب مشاريع
التنمويه اخرى لكن تحويلات ماليه مشبوهه
مرتبطه بالصندوق فجرت فضيحه في عام 2015
ذات اطراف دوليه وادين بسببها عبد الرزاق
بتهم شملت سوء استغلال السلطه وخيانه
الامانه بعد اختلاس اموال من احد فروع
الصندوق السيادي وبحسب وزاره العد
الامريكيه فان اكثر من 4.5 مليار دولار
تدفقت من الصندوق لشركات الوهميه مارست
الاحتيال لتمويل اسراف وفساد المسؤولين عن
الصندوق
قضيه الصندوق الماليزي السيد رئيس الوزراء
اثارت ضجه كبيره شوهت سمعه ماليزيا
الماليه خاصه انها مرتبطه باطراف دوليه
عده كيف يمكن حسم او القضاء على هذه
القضيه
وانهاء تبعاتها واثارها على ماليزيا
حسنا يتم معالجه الامر لقد استعدنا بعض
الاموال قمنا بتشكيل ليان منفصله بما في
ذلك ليان مستقله لمراجعه ما اذا كان لا
يزال بامكان استعاده المزيد وفي الشهر او
الشهرين المقبلين سيتم الاعلان عن الاخبار
الساره قريبا جدا بانه يمكننا استرداد
مبلغ اخر
ولكن المهم هو ان يدرك المجتمع الدولي ان
هذا كان من الماضي ليس من العدل القاء
اللوم على الدوله او على صانع القرار في
الوقت الحالي والذي لا علاقه له بالامر
في الواقع كان احد اسباب دخول السجن هو
انني كنت اول من طرح هذه القضيه في
البرلمان
بعد النظر في تقرير التدقيق الاولي حول
التجاوزات والتهديدات في ذلك الوقت
اكتشفنا مبلغا بسيطا لذلك فان السبيل
الوحيد للهروب هو زي بي في السجن مره اخرى
والان بعد ان اصبحنا قادرين على القيام
بذلك يجب ان نثر للعالم ان هذه كانت حقبه
موسفه في تاريخنا
لكننا سوف نمضي بكل ثقه ووضوح وسياسات
شفافه لاستعاده الثقه خصوصا الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه المباشره في هذا البلد ما طبيعه
الاخبار الساره الاموال ستعود لماليزيا
ومن اي جهه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
حسنا بالتاكيد سيشمل الاعلان ايضا استعاده
بعض الاموال انا لست في وضع يسمح لي
بتقديم تفاصيل لانهم يعقفون الان على وضع
اللمسات الاخيره على الاتفاقيه وثانيا لان
لجنه العمل الخاصه بتتبع الاموال لا تزال
تعمل بجد لاسترجاع الاموال مع قناعه انها
لن تتمكن من استعاده كافه الاموال التي
تعوض خسائرنا كم حجم الامويه كم نسبه ما
يمكن ان يسترجع اكثر من النصف
حسنا الخبر السار هو انه عالميا فان الدول
تعتبر استرجاع 25% من اموالها المنهوبه
شيئا جيدا
ولكننا تمكنا من استرداد 50% من هذه
الاموال ومع الوقت يمكننا ان نتجاوز ذلك
ما يعني انه ليس جيدا لان الاموال لا تزال
تهدر ولكن على الاقل كانت هناك محاوله
محاوله جاده من جانب المؤسسات العامه
البنك المركزي ومؤسسات التنفيذ القانون كم
حجمها كلها سيد انور طيب كم حجم الاموال
الناتجه عن ازمه الصندوق الماليزي
حسنا في الوقت الراهن وقبل ان نتمكن من
استعاده 50% من هذه الاموال كان 35 مليار
دولار مبلغ مغول يعني يعني يغير مسارات
دول 35 مليار اجل على مدى كم سنه كان هذا
كانت عمليه الفساد الناتجه عن الصندوق
الماليزي
لقد كانت متواصله على مدار السنوات العشر
الماضيه لذا فقد استغرق الامر وقتا طويلا
لاسترداد العديد من الاموال
ولكن معظم الاموال يتم استردادها فقط من
خلال بيع اصول الصندوق السيادي الماليزي
ولكن شارك المجتمع الدولي ايضا البعض كان
متعاونا وزاره العدل والقطاع التنفيذي
التابع لحكومه الولايات المتحده
الفيدراليه كانت متعاونه في البدايه
ولكنهم لم يواصلوا العمل لان الاموال تم
الاحتفاظ بها في العديد من المواقع في
جميع انحاء العالم تتعاون معكم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في في طي هذا الملف
اونديس
هذه الحاله بالذات من قبل وزاره العدل نعم
لقد كانوا متفهمين تماما في هذا الموضوع
حتى في الوقت الذي كان فيه رئيس الوزراء
انذاك نجيب هناك كرئيس للوزراء قاموا
بالفعل باصدار بعض الوثائق والبيانات
العامه حول قضيه الصندوق السيادي الماليزي
اود ان اتحدث معك سيد انور حول سياسه
التمييز الايجابيه للمسلمين الملاويين في
ماليزيا الحقيقه انه امر مثير
للاهتمام والانتباه
الا يبدو ان ثمه امور سلبيه ناتجه عن هذا
التمييز تجاه مواطنين اخرين سواء الصينيين
او الهنود
وايضا الا يبدو ان هذا التمييز اسس بنيه
تسمح بفساد السياسيين المنتمين لهذه الفئه
بان لها حظوه لها امتيازات اكبر من غيرها
التمييز الايجابي كاسياسه مقبول اعني انت
تتحدث مع الاقتصاديين السياسيين اشخاص مثل
جلبر اف وهم يقبلون حقيقه انه لا بد من
وجود بعض الاجراءات لمساعده الفقراء
اعني اسود او الملونين في الولايات
المتحده يجب مساعدتهم لانهم تعرضوا
للتهميش لفتره طويله جدا ومن هنا كان هناك
تفاهم وبند في الدستور يشترط منحى بعض
الامتيازات لسكان الاصليين والملاحق
بعدما اوضحته نحن على علم بالتجاوزات وهذه
التجاوزات تقوم على استغلال سياسه التمييز
الايجابي المقدم للسكان الاصليين لاثراء
النخبه السياسيه المحدوده الان
اود ان اقول اننا يجب ان نواصل تقديم
التمييز الايجابي ولا سيما الفقراء
والمسلمين والقبايل الاصليه لكن في الوقت
نفسه يجب ان لا نهمش او نتجاهل الفقراء من
اصل صيني او الفقراء من اصل هندي لذا فان
التمييز الايجابي هو الذي يتجاوز العرق
ليركز على المطالب السياسيه المحدده
للسكان الاصليين مثل المنح الدراسيه
والفرص الدراسيه على ما اعتقد او فرص
العمل هذا بالنسبه لمقبول
من خلال احتكاك مع غير المسلمين او غير
الملاويين هنا اكتشفت ان مصدر احباطهم هو
منح امتيازات بغير وجه حق لمن هم في
السلطه هذه احدى الطرق التي يثرع بها
القاده باستغلال هذه السياسات ولكن اذا
جعلتها سياسه شفافه وما يتم تقديمه بطريقه
واضحه اعتقد انه يمكن لهذه السياسه ان
تستمر
مره اخرى يجب ان تستند الى الحاجه لا الى
مساله العرق ما الاثار السلبيه السيد انور
ابراهيم الاثار السلبيه لسياسه التمييز
التي تم تبنيها في ماليزيا للملاوين
المسلمين السكان الاصلي لها فوائد لكن ما
هي اثارها السلبيه
اذا توليت منصبا وبلغت فيه بشكل كبير فانت
غير مؤهل انت لا تعمل ويتم منحك هذا
الامتياز بسبب العرق هذه بالطبع وصفه
للفشل والكارثه بما في ذلك للملايو يجب ان
تجعلها منافسه عادله حتى بين الملايو اختر
الافضل اختر الاكثر تاهيلا ومن ثم سيقبل
الناس انت تقول ستعطي منح دراسيه اذا
اعطيها للفقراء لابناء الوزراء وهو ما حدث
في الماضي ثم اعتقد ان ذلك سيكون ابعد عن
الشبهات
من المؤكد انني ساخذ موقفا ضد اي شخص بما
في ذلك غير الماليزيين اذا بداوا في
التشكيك في قرار لمساعده الملاي الفقراء
كما تعلم اولئك الذين تم حرمانهم في بعض
المناطق النائيه التي لا توجد بها مرافق
طبيه مناسبه مع عدد محدود من المدارس
الاله للسقوط يجب ان تتم مساعدتهم لان
العداله الاجتماعيه ليست مجرد مساواه لابد
من انصافهم يمكن ان تكون المنافسه داخليه
كما تعلم بين مدرسه النخبه ومدرسه في قلب
البلاد
لذلك يجب ان ندرك ان جزءا من الشعور
بالعداله هو انصاف جميع المجتمعات وعدم
اهمالها حين يشعر افراد المجتمع انهم
يتعرضون للتهميش او التمييز عندها سيتولد
الاستياء لهذا السبب في ادارتنا الان نريد
ان نكون اكثر شموليه
افرضوا العوامل الجيو السياسيه على
ماليزيا تعامل الحذرا مع كل من الصين
والولايات المتحده وتمتلك كوالالمبور من
الاوراق ما يجعل علاقاتها متوازنه بكل من
واشنط وبكين وبمنع عن الاصطفاف الكامل مع
احدى القوتين فيما يتعلق ببكين فان روابطك
لنحو 1000 عام خلت وفي عام
1974 طبعت الحكومه الماليزيه علاقاتها مع
الصين لتكون اول حكومه منتخبات ديمقراطيه
من بين دول مجموعه الاسيان تقدم على هذه
الخطوه اخذت هذه الروابط تتوثق بالطراد
محققه قفزات متتاليه جعلت الصين شركه
التجاري الاول لماليزيا طيله الاعوام ال14
الاخيره بالانقطاع ليبلغ حجم التجاره
البينيه بينهما العام الماضي قرابه
المئتين مليار دولار وهو ما يمثل نحوه ربع
التجاره الاجماليه لماليزيا حرصت ماليزيا
على الابتعاد عن كل ما من شانه تهكير صفو
العلاقات مع الصين رغم النزاع القائم
بينهم على السياده في بعض مناطق بحر الصين
الجنوبي لكنها في الوقت نفسه دافعت عن
استقلاليه سياساتها الخارجيه ردا على
انتقادات طالت حكومتها متهمه اياها بارضاء
الصين القوه العظمى اما الولايات المتحده
فتظل شريكا دبلوماسيا وتنمويا مهما
لماليزيا كما انها ثالث اكبر شريك تجاري
للبلاد بعد الصين وسنغافوره وتحتضن
ماليزيا حاليا اكثر من 600 شركه امريكيه
ذات استثمارات كبيره في قطاعات الكهرباء
والالكترونيات والطاقه المتجدده ويسعى
الجانبان الى مزيد من التعاون في مجالات
تتزايد اهميتها كالصحه العامه وسلاسل
التوريد والاقتصاد الرقمي وخلال العام
الماضي نمى اجمال التجاره بين ماليزيا
والولايات المتحده بنسبه
23.3% متخطيا حاجز الستين مليار دولار
مقارنه بنحو 52 مليار دولار في عام 2021
اقدر اتحدث الان عن اتجاهات السياسه
الخارجيه
لماليزيا في في عهدكم بعد توليكم رئاسه
الوزراء
ماليزيا تقع بين المطرقه والسندان بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبين الصين
الصين شريكم التجاري الاكبر منذ عام 2009
ولكن انتم ايضا حلفاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انور ابراهيم اين يقع قلبه
وضميره واتجاهاته يقال انه انور ابراهيم
غربي الهوى هل هذه دقيقه ام تهمه
[ضحك]
ايوز الشاهد
نعم انا البس قميصا انا لا البسه لباس
الملا الذي البسه عاده كل يوم جمعه انا
ماليزي والصين جاره مهمه للغايه وشريك
تجاري رئيسي وهناك استثمارات ضخمه
لماليزيا كانت امريكا حليفه تقليديه كانت
الاستثمارات الاوليه وتطور الصناعي
التكنولوجي موجوده منذ اكثر من نصف قرن
وكذلك كانت اوروبا
[موسيقى]
الشرق الاوسط بعض بلدانه كالسعوديه وقطر
والامارات كما تعلمون شركاء مقربون لنا
منذ عقود هل تميز احدهم هل تحابي اي شخص
لا بلدنا بلد تجاري صغير اعتقد انه من
مصلحه جميع الماليزيين ان ظل قريبين جدا
من الصين
ماليزيا منخرطه في علاقات وديه للغايه مع
الولايات المتحده وفي الواقع مع المجتمع
الدولي
هذا هو ايضا موقف رابطه الدول جنوب شرق
اسيا اعني ان الصراع بين امريكا والصين
مؤسف لا يعطينا مهله بل يسبب لنا الكثير
من المشاكل لكننا مجرد دوله صغيره وسيتعين
علينا العمل مع كليهما
لكن حقيقه انني معتاد جيدا على التدريس في
الولايات المتحده ولدي ارتباطات معهم لكن
هذا لا يجعلني منحازا بالتاكيد انا لست
منحازا لهم لدي اراء قويه ضد بعض مواقف
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه اعني فيما
يتعلق بالفلسطينيين لكنه لا يمنعنا من
التعامل معهم واعتبارهم اصدقاء في حين
نختلف حول بعض القضايا توترات مع الصين في
بحر الصين الجنوبي بين ماليزيا لا تؤثر
على علاقاتكم مع الصين كقوه رئيسيه في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
لا ليس صحيحا لاننا نتخذ موقفا غير موافق
تماما في بعض الحالات التي ينظر اليها على
انها اكثر عدوانيه من التعدي الصيني على
بعض اراضينا
لكن حتى الان لم يكن الامر قاتلا او خطيرا
نحن نلجا للعلاقات الثنائيه ضمن اسيا
لاتخاذ موقف يحترم حدود بعضنا البعض لم
يكن التعدي خطيرا رغم اننا نشعر ببعض
القلق بسبب ظهور بعض السفن او اي سفن
دوليه تظهر ببطء في حدود ماليزيا والتي
يبدو انهم سيقولون لا لانهم ايضا لديهم
مطالبهم لذا لمثل هذه الحالات اعتقد ان
الافضل هو مواصله هذا الحوار الهادف بين
هذه الدول ماليزيا دوله مسلمه
وتعبر عن حاله اسلاميه ايضا استثنائيه
مميزه انور ابراهيم اسلامي يعني في تاريخه
وفي توجهاته قضيه الايغور في الصين وما
يتعرضون لهم من اضطهاد ومن
تمييز مجحف بشكل كبير جدا الا يؤثر ايضا
على العلاقه مع الصين الا يدفعكم مثلا
التزامكم الاسلامي
لمحاوله التاثير على على مساله الحقوق
لمجتمع الايجار المسلم في الصين
[موسيقى]
هذه هي قضايا حقوق الانسان التي يجب ان
يهتم بها اي انسان نزيه سواء كانوا من
الايغور او الفلسطينيين او كما تعلم او
الرهن
اذا كيف تتعامل هل ستعتبر انها مشكله
داخليه لقضيه مثل قضيه لم يعد الامر يتعلق
بشؤوننا الداخليه لان لدينا 200 الف لاجئ
هنا في ماليزيا وعلينا تلبيه احتياجاتهم
والسبب الرئيسي يتعلق بميان ومره اخرى نحن
فيما يتعلق بالايغور نمارس حقنا في
التعامل مع الصينيين لاننا نرى انها شان
داخليه كما ان الصينيين اكدوا انهم
سيعاملونهم معام حسنه كما تعلمون لقد
طرحنا ايضا جزءا من مخاوفنا وهذه هي
المفاوضات او عرض هذه المخاوف على
الصينيين لكنني اعتقد اننا نقوم بذلك على
الاريح في مراحل مختلفه من خلال شبكه
سياستنا الخارجيه للتاكد من عدم تفاقمها
وخلق بعض التعقيدات فيما يتعلق بعلاقاتنا
الوديه الجيده بين الصين وماليزيا يعني
ماليزيا بلد اسيوي وجزء من الاسيان لاعب
رئيسي في المنطقه وايضا بلد مسلم كيف
تنظرون لدور ماليزيا في العالم الاسلامي
دورها كبلد اسلامي اليوم
ويرويها من صفات
[موسيقى]
اسلام لقد كنا داعمين لعلاقات العمل سواء
من خلال المؤتمر الاسلامي او العلاقات
الثنائيه ادرك اننا كنا نشطين منذ البدايه
كان اول امين عام لمنظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي
تمت دعوته من قبل ملك السعوديه المرحوم
فيصل هو رئيس وزرائنا السابق تنقو عبد
الرحمن لذلك سوف نستمر في لعب هذا الدور
مع جميع البلدان ولكننا نطلب ايضا المشوره
من كبار اعضاء المجتمع الدولي وانا اتطلع
الى التعامل معهم
انا لا ازور ايا من هذه البلدان باستثناء
تركيا التي قمت بزيارتها لمده نصف يوم فقط
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضربها اتطلع لزياره
الدول جميعها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اجل هذا كان في الايام الماضيه
ذهبت الى هناك وزرت الموقع ثم التقيت
بالرئيس اردوغان وعود شكرا لك سيدي نور
ابراهيم رئيس الوزراء الماليزي شكر لموصول
لكم مشاهدينا الكرام خصصت هذا الجزء
للحديث عن عما هو راهن من الاحداث عن
القضايا الملحه واتجاهات السياسه
الماليزيه في الفتره القادمه وفي الجزء
القادم سنخصص النقاش لمسيره انور ابراهيم
الطويله والصعبه والاستثنائيه والتي عادت
به مجددا الى سده رئاسه الوزراء شكرا لكم
في امان الله
[موسيقى]